all right as this major foreign policy
crisis uh unfolds overseas GOP
Presidential candidates they're all
weighing in vake Ras Swami released his
six-point plan to tackle the situation
in Israel while taking shots at other
candidates specifically Nikki Haley now
vake is calling for intelligence and
weapon sharing with Israel uh the
immediate appointment of an ambassador
to Israel to end nuclear proliferation
in the Middle East the deportation of
illegals here in the US who have worked
with Hamas and much more and be be Rob
mwami joins us now I I looked at your
list and and this the only disagreement
I have is I don't really disagree on a
lot of your points but the intelligence
sharing was
unprecedented uh and a coalition was
formed when President Trump was in
office where it was the US it was Israel
it was Egypt it was Jordan it was the
Saudis it was the Emirates all standing
United Ed against Iranian hegemony in
the region to prevent them from ever
acquiring nuclear weapons so we have had
that before
be yeah absolutely and Sean one of the
things I've said is that while everybody
else seems to say this is a question for
later I think this is a question for now
we need to understand what the heck went
wrong with both us and Israeli
intelligence as well as Israeli defense
think about an airplane when it crashes
the black box is not analyzed by The
Airliner who was responsible for the
crash we need independent answers to
that question but my number one Focus
Sean is on one hand we have to support
Israel in the decisions that Israel
makes to defend itself they have a right
to National self-existence and what
happened there was wrong and barbaric
and medieval by Hamas on the other hand
I'm the only Republican saying this this
is our also moment to be cool-headed not
emotional but rational in our response
to make sure that we don't inadvertently
enter a US involved broader regional
conflict in the Middle East that does
not Advance American interests and I
believe we can do both of those things
well but part of the reason I have
criticized the Republicans is that the
emotional response I think is unhelpful
saying finish them saying just do it we
need to be very specific about exactly
what we're going to do coolheadedness in
times of Crisis is essential and that's
how I would lead as commanderin-chief if
if you look at this exponential and you
look at the population of Israel and the
population of the US it would be the
moral equivalent of
36,000 Americans killed on our soil in a
single day uh what would you want
America's response to be because I could
tell you what I really predict is going
to happen Gaza is going to be
annihilated and they're going to end
hamas's reign in Gaza that will be over
and I don't think there's going to be
much for people to go back to
there that is going to be Israel's
decision to make and we should support
whatever decision they do make I will
tell you this though Sean now is the
moment to remember we have made some of
our own most disastrous decisions in the
wake of tragedies including after 911
look at $3 trillion wasted in Iraq and
Afghanistan thousands upon thousands of
American lives sacrificed to what end
the Taliban still in charge in
Afghanistan 20 years later a hostile
anti-American regime in Iraq vulnerable
to Iranian incursion in Iraq today so if
I'm talking to BB if I'm the president
of the United States I'm going to offer
him both compassion sympathy support but
also our learnings to say we've made
mistakes in the United States in
response to tragedy we will share those
lessons with you coolheadedness is
important should they offer bunker
Buster bombs to take out nuclear sits in
Iran yes or no I got to
go I think the US should offer Israel
limited Munitions to be able to defend
itself against Hamas and the attacks I
think we should be very careful
ESC into aoad Regional war in the Middle
East well Sean there's a lot of
circumstances that are still changing
but the principle for me no broader
Regional War while still supporting
Israel's defense hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else